things are starting to get really bad
for Donald Trump jr. the FBI now has
secret wiretaps from Spanish police of a
conversation between Alexander tortion
who's an official of Russia's central
bank who we've discussed before because
he was part of that story involving
Russia funneling money through the NRA
to the Trump campaign and these wiretaps
that the FBI has reportedly led to a
meeting between Donald Trump jr. and
Alexander tortion oh lordy there are
tapes at least some of them and Jose
Grenda who's been investigating Spanish
organized crime for a very long time was
asked about whether there's concern that
tortion had meetings with Donald Trump
jr. and Grenda said quote mr. Trump's
son should be concerned and this is now
starting to get beyond anything we could
call innocent coincidences the lead
Russian guy who was revealed by the
McClatchy investigation which we
interviewed vivica Nova Novak about as
being a primary player in the funneling
of Russian funds to the Trump campaign
through the NRA which of course would be
against the law met with Donald Trump
jr. and there are wiretaps related to
that meeting that tortion had with Trump
jr. so let's go through it layer by
layer number one the fact that the FBI
has these wiretaps implies tortion is of
interest to the FBI which means that any
combination of the meeting with Trump
jr. to the funneling of money through
the NRA might now be part of Robert
Moeller's investigation number two Spain
is now involved with this and is
cooperating with the FBI that's another
indication as to the size and scope of
this entire thing number three the idea
that this entire Muller investigation is
almost over who believes that when Spain
just entered the proceedings over the
last couple of months very difficult to
believe
and then lastly how far have the goal
posts moved right at some point and it
seems like ancient history at this point
the Trump campaign said no one in the
campaign had any contact with
it seems hilarious to even think back to
that at this point Jeff sessions said it
and Donald Trump said it and everybody
said it who's even talking about that is
the standard anymore the discussion now
is what of the contact was criminal if
any was there obstruction to try to hide
that contact we never met with Russians
became there were meanings but they
weren't about anything - there were
meetings about helping our campaign but
they never actually did end up helping
the campaign and now it's becoming hey
listen there was all sorts of stuff
going on but none of it was actually
against the law and if it was Hillary
would have done the exact same thing
anyway or she already did and then the
last point I want to make about this is
Jose Grenda the Spanish investigator
saying that Trump jr. should be
concerned
Jose Grenda has been a major
investigator in Spain of organized crime
he's not a guy that you want to mess
with he's made his career investigating
organized crime and corruption in Spain
he's saying merely on the basis of what
he has found that Donald Trump jr.
should be worried the response from
trumpets they always have one here it is
deep state right I mean deep state if
ever there was proof that there was an
international conspiracy to take down
Donald Trump over nothing more than a
witch hunt it's that now even the
Spanish are involved so obviously it's a
deep state conspiracy that we need to
expose here stunning that this is going
on and this isn't even the only story
from the weekend like this we also
learned during our long weekend that
days before his inauguration in January
of 2017 Donald Trump's personal lawyer
well days before Trump's inauguration
Trump's personal lawyer Michael Cohen
met with another Russian at Trump Tower
so that's gonna have to be a story for
another day maybe but I think what's
clear is that this was supposed to be
over by last Thanksgiving if you believe
these people clearly it's not going to
be over anytime soon